what up reject nation we gonna watch ourselves
the first episode of moon night today of course
joined by our great friend koi john drow
here our comic book expert easily knows moon
knight slightly better than john reading that's
right he's he's been reading he's an expert now
hey of course full length watch long as we stick
it with the timecode or over at our patreon page
become a superject today by checking all the
content we got to offer over there thank you for
the support and if you can't join our patreon page
the least you can do is leave a like subscribe and
click the notification bell also get notified when
our reaction for the next episode of moon knight
is up lastly them handsome devils over at prepper
you keep the light on for me and the moon of
it's gotta be arthur harrow
right sure looks like ethan hawk
oh yeah oh god oof it's a disney
show get that self-flagellation boy
oh boy that's how you open a moon night
yes sir every kid on their disney plus app has got
a crazy idea now crazy ideas ruining
the children oh man what a great intro
great mirroring and then literally mirroring
that's great they believed you needed your
heart to be judged in the underworld and only
the worthiest would be allowed to pass through
the field to read and did it suck for you
getting rejected from the field of reads
what if that makes sense because i'm not dead
oh my god some corner foreshadowing is happy oh
that accent's gonna be a thing they're like figs
and dates and fight [ __ ] my next horse here but
seven tomorrow best steak in
town oh yeah yeah right so sorry
are you asking me out you're funny it's
gonna be an awkward ass date dad rascal
i didn't know you're taking a crack she's
dating mark the banners and the posters
of the aniad so what the any ad you know like
the super group of egyptian gods you know
you've got shoes stop please if this is some weird
audition to tour guide here the answer is still no
i know what that's actually crashing to here oh
buddy i swear i'll shove you in a sarcophagus
you can tell the bloody pharaoh in there
what's wrong with him and oh foreshadowing
you shanna you're from london did
you take a picture of us yeah sure
thank you yeah we're going on a date i didn't
even ask her i don't know how it happened you
think he's friends with all the personalities
oh that'd be fun i am going to have a girlfriend
at some point obviously can't have
ankle restraints on my bed can i
not you never know find yourself someone kinky
some people are into that sort of thing stephen
hello and welcome to staying awake let's start
with trying to solve a puzzle reading can keep
your mind alert and focused imagine being in
the story you're reading this is a square game
soundtrack sounds a little like yeah solving
puzzles is a great way to keep your mind awake
between god and man
oh
surrender the body to mark of course friend of
the body what body ah the idiot's in control
yes
that's good though keep zig zagging that's smart
i judge you in amit's name with
but a fraction of her power
this is the face of a good man
there's one out there found them who would
like to go next please hello i must know
oh i've been good my entire life i believe you but
the scales see everything perhaps it's something
that lies ahead oh no i wish you could live to
see the world we make lies ahead she's like 90.
fingers froze oh that's so good me every time
i handle them being taunted oh that's so good
i don't know what's happening
there we go just take a picture
oh god
oh dude
this is so good
windy road reflective of his state
understand what's is
oh no
nice wow final destination
oh my god
he just throw the gun down
he must be parasite ouch
it was all just a dream guys that's
it show's over we'll put a bunch of
[ __ ] just go back to the gift shop how many
footsteps are going to be around the sand
how are we doing ghost sheep all
right i wonder what fishes dream about
oh my god they put in the fish stick
oh this finn's back what fish oh the fish
yesterday that fish had one fin yeah he would like
that when i bought him today what do you see i see
two fins yeah sorry is that clock right no that's
impossible i just woke up you're mad the fish is
wrong the time is wrong you're not quite right
fish is going on a date what the fish bring them
with you you wanted to show them the world fin man
oh that imagery is going to be fun later symbolism
ah symbolism definitely because of
all the different slabs and the red
each pane of glass represents pain anything
with multiple dividing lines is awesome
i think friday still comes after thursday
doesn't it it doesn't change the fact
that today is sunday which means lose my
number oh oh i still got to see our work
buddy i'll have the best bit of the
uh that's the bit that i want oh man
oh it's good to have oscar isaac at the
mcu that's exactly what i was thinking
like i think how lucky are we
here it's just one character
or something anyway i'll tell you more
about it tomorrow love you later gators
that's a new quote moon knight t-shirts with
the loki gator it's an easter egg reference
that shot was a metaphor for loneliness
disk disk
good old razer phone
been texting and calling you for a month i
just found this phone in my flat and i'm just
trying to figure out who's it is what is with this
accent who do you think i am what do you mean who
what's wrong with you mark why did you call
me mark no no no no no come on come on laila
oh yeah
thank you kill her don't trust her are we back on
the fifth floor yes the thief my friend
claire lives here she's expecting me
what's going on
it's like a j horror movie oh good call yeah
oh no
see you really do work here oh i'd assumed steven
grant was an alias imagine my surprise to find
you here excuse me ronnie this man right here
he's been following me no i don't know please
they own everything ronnie the country the scarab
doesn't belong to me it belongs to her do you know
ahmed she knows what we've done or what we will do
great okay well books must have left that part out
oh my god all the patrons she would have prevented
hitler and the destruction he wrote near the
armenian genocide pol pot but she was betrayed
by even her own avatar avatars blue people
beat us to the joke stephen
do you want to know the truth
there are things to go bump
in the night this chaos in you
and we gotta eat that hawk in
here they did like this is so good
yeah it's really good i hear you can you hear me
are you about to get us an anubis
terrible god
wow
i think it's terrifying you need
to give me control you understand
control of what you're talking about that
thing's about to break through the door
we're out of time it's like
a universal studio's ride
great choreography you're not gonna die
let me save us
oh it just chills just everywhere so many moments
moon knight theme song yes look at them
you're stuck in here with me
beautiful beautiful work hell yeah wow step out of
the way hawkeye episode one we got a new favorite
goddamn i'm so glad they saved like i never knew
oscar isaac's voice like i'm so glad they saved
mark from all of the marketing yeah yeah yeah
because it felt exciting to hear just oscar isaac
yeah he's so good at that like i dawned on me like
in the middle of like i i don't see an accent at
all like it's that thing where you just think
that's his voice you would assume that if this is
the first time you're seeing oscar isaac i would
go oh the american accent's the voice he's putting
on yeah yeah and the duality between that like
nasally it sounds you know insecure versus his
commanding isaac voice as well as the accent
yeah you know that's an easter egg i am just
a nazi direction well he's just trying like like
three and a half oh my god ex it did leave me with
a question though did he ask that girl out with an
american accent and then she was like and then she
was just like whatever british now he's got he's
got jokes i i assume everyone thinks he's you know
f murray abraham nice so it was not sean connery
from beyond no no i'm trying to bring him back
yeah let's get all those ai voices that always
go god that is a beautiful closing credits
what a stunning show visually like they're
really great at expressive camera work even
express yourself just express
yourself don't hurt anybody i like
knew i'd like the show and i didn't know how
hard it would go like you know everyone's been
concerned about disney to the point where i
was like starting to believe them and that was
really violent oh i signed my age restriction you
know pin and everything that give me business now
here it is i mean that that's moon
knight like they they accomplish the
really pondersome tone when he's piecing together
like the the existential dread but they also
the cinematography reads like the comics which
have this really uh i mean have you read the greg
smallwood illustrated stuff yet is that the six
issue one yeah no i i i i'm gonna get that okay
so the visuals there remind me so much mdm right
now yeah the smallwood visuals there you'll see
all right what are you thinking no i don't
even talk there i'm good with just sitting
and taking it in just absorbing i feel like
i need to be a goddamn critic to watch us
watch us i'm trying to take in the credits here we
are that's what i really came to the show for just
see all the jobs they created that's beautiful
work you guys was talking i missed a casting
associate in the uk thanks [ __ ] the transport
coordinator though transport is important there
should be an oscar for best transpo uh easter
egg i did notice that wasn't oh credits okay
egg cupcake truck it was a lack of easter
egg because everybody's like it's fondue
i don't think it's on the cupcakes i
don't know who actually believed that
a lot of people but you guys are crazy this
is actually the most separated from the mcu
out of them all that's why i don't like i
didn't notice a lot of strikes personally
i didn't feel and i'm i'm glad because the
eternal scenes where they were like shoehorning in
marvel felt off to the tone of the film or
is this actually at the very end i like the
opinion of non-praise about the eternals there
is the occasional flaw what in a very good fight
occasion we'll fly you like
everything that's not true everything
and i cut that out of the actual
video and now it's on the wreck
now you know a throwback to
a cut joke and now it's real
let's talk about it let's talk about it all
right you know let's do this differently okay
go our new comic book aficionado yes the one
everybody wants to hear from no i love this
i thought this was really really terrific
and yeah i mean you know from my extensive
knowledge now of the comics i mean this does
feel very spiritually sound i mean yeah steven
has been a bit re-contextualized but i like the
choice to do that i think he's a really effective
yeah i mean he's not the billionaire guy you know
the philanthropist playboy or whatever i like the
choice to really bring us into his world as a
character who is a bit more nebushy and down on
his luck and i love the disorientation they throw
you for with all these things that are happening
in an episode like this they have to be economical
with that time and i thought the way that they
managed to hop to so many different things
utilizing that lapse in consciousness was really
smart all the way through their camera work was so
complementary and so expressive to the point where
like all of these are incredibly finely crafted
but this was a show this episode alone was an
episode where i was like no shot is wasted here
everything feels like it has a lot of thought put
into it oscar isaac it's it's hard to say enough
things about him and even though we've only had
a few glimpses at uh arthur harrow ethan hawke
i i love his presence as well and i love that
even though he does have a sinister quality about
him there's something that isn't very uh your boy
even though there is a sinister quality
about him something about him that doesn't
seem like you know he's a mustache twirler you
know like i like his dedication his devotion
to you know this you know almost
profit-like role that he is playing
you know in conjunction with the gods
and i just can't wait to see more yeah
i loved it uh i love that there was a moment
where we all went like oscar isaac there was
one like acting choice after another that was so
interesting so captivating and it's really hard
because of the big change they did with steven uh
i think it's smart to have the batman similarities
separate because there's enough people talking
about how he's marvel's batman so you get rid of
the playboy first uh so i love that the duality
between mark and steven is that direction about
weakness and strength and i really enjoyed the
disorientation we as an audience experienced
having only steven's perspective we only got to
experience that and then his disorientation of
losing time and losing cognizance so it it would
be his perspective what i'm curious is is if we'll
get an episode where it's like we're with mark the
whole time or if we're in an episode where we like
meet the third identity and we we lose time or if
they played that just for the pilot and now we're
gonna or i don't know if they're considered
pilots if you get a season order but you know
what i mean if we're gonna play with uh different
personalities or now that we've already dealt with
these two if it'll be more streamlined more more
narrative structure uh that being said i loved
ethan hawk so much i think he's so talented but
seeing him in this this darkness i like that it
mirrored the footsteps like we we got that opening
that was that was you know his his punishing self
flagulation but we also then saw uh the the walk
of moon knight i do think we're gonna see a lot
more similarities in this hero villain pairing
as we meet mark i think we're going to see how
similar they are and i really liked that it
opened with the villain in this case and then
followed through yeah you know the filmmakers they
did say or one of the creators said that this is
like fight club meets indiana jones i couldn't
agree more like already from the first episode i
could just imagine how much more archaeological
swashbuckling this is all gonna feel like this
didn't feel like r-rated to me or any stretch it
doesn't feel like it's our i don't know it's just
the first episode but the first episode was more
like that dark pg-13 supernatural horror flare
that i really love and especially like staying
within the museum it is like indiana jones
national treasure but like better than national
treasure one of those flares that i really liked
a lot locking it into solely steven's perspective
a gives you a character to really endear yourself
to you know it's like there's aphemisms about
them that kind of remind you of a bit like uh
how you get kind of endeared like toby maguire the
first spider-man movie like everyone just seems to
pick on this guy when he's when he's just a such
a softy you know pathetic even chase is a bust
like peter a little pathetic yeah even chase is
a bus like peter at the very top of it locking it
into his perspective allows you to do some very
interesting camera choices and editing choices
that can be kind of shocking and cool and also
that much more immersive and i thought that was
one of the most unique things about what they
did here was actually having the delays those
shifts those visual motifs without showing you
the events when they're without showing you what
mark specter is doing when he's taking over makes
it more immersive to not actually see it which is
so unique like you don't get usually to make an
immersive you've got to really envelop yourself
in the actual thing that's happening in the
present moment but throwing you into what
he's going through really puts you there doesn't
make me curious like what the overall character
arc will be for him because obviously they've
established like i've had that same thought too
i've expressed that quite a few times the three
main person is like jake stephen and mark in the
comments i met jake we haven't met jake we don't
even know if he exists yet uh within this world or
if it will be introduced it'll be the post credit
scene very yeah luckily get in my cat weird thing
this is his arc the way how the people were like
bruce wayne in the billionaire playboy in batman
this is it this is ark into becoming a billionaire
playboy the first my way that's where the money
is well i was wondering like what the what the
character arc will ultimately be will it be one
of those things where because it seems like we're
going to have some of that almost venom and eddy
thing where he you know he's it's interacting with
kanchu within his head can we talk about a great
country looks conscious conscious looks great that
bus scene i think might be my favorite when he's
just standing there for a few frames and then
disappears just the scope of them the size the
ethereal like up close we'd seen a couple shots
but the the scope of what they were able to do
and making him feel tangible but intangible at
the same time absolutely i think what they did
with his music with the music around them too and
usually around this whole show like they had some
needle drops but then they also had some
just original score that had that like
operatic egyptian flair to it and sometimes
was very pulsating the scene work between
arthur harrow and stephen grant is is phenomenal
what excites me most is because when you get two
actors like that they understand the importance of
dynamics and the relationship so when we have mark
specter interacting with arthur harrow it's gonna
be like a completely different scene it's gonna
be like two different actors are interacting with
each other you know and you have that calvin actor
for that reason cause apparently you know they're
friends and that's how ethan hawk got brought on
so i love the idea that they're actually going
like no no we want to have this fight this actor
fight like we want to have this ted attack
speaking to what you're saying about the arc
i really think it's going to be interesting to see
if the show lands with him being able to control
his identities more and be and being able to
decide which one is serving the best purpose
because in the comics sometimes that's the
case not always but i do think it's gonna be
interesting if mark takes over to a level that
we see you know the badass kind of steering
more it's gonna be like that scene in the two
towers when gollum is like talking with himself
yeah go away and never return go i never return
later yeah that action scene was really well shot
i think this just strikes a really cool mood and a
really good mystery but also keeping it refreshing
and what makes oscar isaac's performance i think
so strong just how much this all weighs on him
like starting it off where he just has no you
guys are using the word disorientation a lot
so i'll use it you know everyone
used to work dance for eternals
yeah so that's the news orientation
disorientation disney plus disorientation
oscar isaac's performance is just how much
that weighs on that's why that restaurant
scene was so powerful it wasn't just that like
oh my god he's crying whoa good acting you know
which is the mark of any good actor he cries
that's all you got good acting all right
that's all you need a lot of anger and a lot of
crying good acting it's the way he interacted
like he's not receiving at all what the waiter is
telling him like he's vegan they established that
he's giving in to the meat just like succumbing to
it something he's had to like kind of discipline
himself i imagine to resist that like something's
like little as that some sort of nuance but to
make that choice but clearly he likes meat and
then he has to he's going to get something that
has had to disappoint himself to go against
because he's just falling apart internally but
he's just asking all these questions just like
it'd be so polite so affable yeah yeah whatever
yeah okay uh-huh that's good but you can see him
just breaking down while trying to put on a face
ah powerful stuff so yeah i think oscar isaac's
performance here is just so strong like i care
so much i care so much about stephen grant this
is the first marvel show that they introduced a
character right like as your protagonist that
bishop was the closest but that was still like
the jumping off point was we got clint barton i
think it's the clock this is all brand new people
like everyone here and that's why i was saying i'm
glad there's not a lot of easter eggs not a lot of
references a lot of i like that we get to live
in the supernatural by itself for a second i'm
not looking for stuff maybe i shouldn't be but i'm
enjoying like just the experience of it and also i
keep bringing them up but greg smallwood's uh his
art style has this really beautiful kind of like
pencil shading aesthetic to the underneath and
i'm loving how they're using shading i'm loving
how they're using like darkness versus light i
love the little detail of having a white hood
but like the use of lighting is playing into how
i visually see the comic books there's always this
very heavy inked book and it makes it obviously
the supernatural tone but it also feels like more
of a translation of the comic to the screen than
some of the other shows have for me personally
like sometimes the comic it feels like a marvel
show like they're going for a marvel color palette
this doesn't feel like a marvel color palette
it feels like the comic inks are on screen yeah
yeah yeah it's got really expressive light and
i love that you name check j-horror because it
definitely has a certain element of that which
is also very inky in a very sort of depth of the
shadows kind of genre and two we talked about
in one of the trailer reactions about how you
know they're talking about this is going to be a
level up in terms of how harsh you know a marvel
disney flush show can get and i've never been one
to think that they'll go daredevil netflix level
but i do appreciate that like in that scene
where he kills those people there is blood
and the blood on his hand is very striking
and it made me go we don't really often see
blood of consequence in these things and even
that was something that was like really striking
just from a color and just from a palette
sort of standpoint well i think the most
survey these thoughts at the opening scene
stepping into a sandal full of glasses
that was so cool and that's such a bold way to
open any show much less a disney show like any
show opening that way it's like what am i
watching what am i investing in i can just
imagine a whole family getting around got the new
marvel show river hawkeye oh my gosh remember that
christmas show we just watched man what is the
life let's put on moon night now it's spring
i also i think it was really smart to keep all
of the marketing largely in the first episode
like most of the stuff we saw in the trailers
was it here i know i've picked the whole series
together oh okay i'm sorry yeah i know what's
going on yeah here we go that's why you know
about the cabbie at the end it's all about the
fish right to the podium damn it these fish has
all the ends underneath all along gus the fish
is gus the fish a future head avenger that's
the question definitely definitely that's the
big easter guys the easter egg starts the pet
events got you just all four minutes you thought
they were going young avengers no no it's a dog
alligator from loki loki gator perfect yeah we got
i mean that's five that's an avengers team yeah
do it cut the check i stopped listening i know
you guys felt that listen moon night's done
everyone's done today listen uh follow koi
over on his um [ __ ] you forgot to tell me
i got a youtube and tick tock oh at the top
top of the show i'll just put a little logo
on a [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm the worst it's my fault
could you just yeah give me one assignment it
just reminds me of how you're talking about
i thought my assignment was to know moonlight
the show doesn't even really need you to
know moonlight that's nice though right now
are unnecessary how approachable the show is
considering how dense to use your word moon
oh yeah disorienting listen uh i can follow us
on patreon thanks john for um doing it all man
he's in the moonlight experience the moon not
an expert there's probably a split personality
of john that just knows everything yeah
he's never here when i freaking beat him
if i i would be always in steven graham
right i would be so upset to find out
the complete shadow relief of all the things
i struggle with that's just like a guy jolly
reading like your cut scene is this guy like oh
that's nice gone completely useless one thing
before we go arthur harrow i like the way they
have drawn him as this prophet for people this uh
savior it's such a unique way of cleansing
the world of talking about bringing heaven to
earth of all right let the god judge whether or
not you're a good person or not okay you're bad
we're wiping you off that is fascinating it's
a it's a fresh spin on the environmentalist
villain that we see all the time you know yeah
and left that notes planned like heaven's gatey
sort of cultism too yeah it's a lot of stuff it's
more individualized it's a much more like personal
way to kill somebody like you're you're seeing
it's almost like the penance there with ghost
tracker was it like a nazi in the comics or
something yeah i mean definitely like that
but with a hydra it doesn't really work
as well but yeah like definitely in that
tonality moon night pick up a comic today kids
yeah and step on some glass while you're at it
there's a secret shelf kelly vereer i couldn't
think of anything then thank you for being here
guess who is josh faroo bet you never
heard of this one randy boom film star
damian chappa mendoza mr jimmy burns king alan
ling jacob i want to climb your ladder height
ted theodore logan burton guster ericans 39
dudes tootsie fruitsy cousy cousy justin will
smith uncle phil eider carlton there's a bear in
the garage nick x is not a fresh prince character
longshlong juan longoria gail fergie ferguson
jaren fergie wanner cliff the big red rodriguez
crispy thrust in the busting if i were alex biwer
i'd learn how to say your name right master t the
o g pseudonymous entity the o o g olivia the
wise guy and the funk nuff said lorenzo baxter
i tried doing a round burger dinner giftedly
differently same levitt odell good he smells
ralph lauren american eagle polo has a horse
insignia simply pimply faded pimples pimps
anyway guys thank you so much for pledging to
our patreon your support has gotten us through
the best of times things were already
good and you just made it even better
so thank you seriously tell the best receive it
receive the gratitude thank you say thank you
when i say thank you you say no thank you
you're welcome